hey guys and welcome to episode number
six of my GE only challenge uh today
we're starting off with no new goals uh
reached unfortunately uh but we are
slowly creeping up to the 750 total
level as well as the 10 mil uh buyable
goal for either the player owned house
or to unlock herblore uh now I've kind
of come to the realization that I'm not
realistically going to get 750 total uh
without getting one of the bable skills
that's defin possible but uh it's going
to be quicker to just get to 10 mil and
unlock uh my PO uh cuz that will unlock
uh farming as well and increase my total
level much more than grinding out uh my
skills to a higher level at least at
this point so I've decided I think I'm
going to go with construction first
mainly just for the sole reason that I
will uh speed up my farming levels I can
finally get to level 15 farming and then
unlock the actual tree farming patch uh
now I have a couple questions about this
as well what do you guys think do you
think I should uh buy my p as soon as I
have 10 mil like buy it right away and
that will maybe get left over with a
little bit of money or do you think I
should flip my way make more money until
I get to say 15 mil cash ATT or 20 mil
cash de uh the benefit there being is
once I spend the money I'll have more
left over uh the benefit of buying it
right away is I can start training my
farming up right away because it's time
dependent I'll have more farming levels
and uh more total levels uh so yeah
definitely leave a comment uh with your
guys' suggestions regarding that and
thanks again for tuning in to episode 6
and let's get started okay so we're
starting off today's episode with some
flips uh but I did notice in the last
episode I got some feedback that people
didn't seem to want to see uh flips all
the time so we're definitely going to
try to mix up the content uh we're going
to get our skills up a lot in this
episode uh that being said we do have
some potion flips in most notably the
super anti poisons giving us about
130k margin on the full bind limit uh
which is pretty good
okay so we're buying 4,270 Maple logs
this should be enough to get us I
believe at least UH 60 plus that should
be enough um but yeah Maple logs are
going to be profitable which is nice uh
we're going to get some decent fling
experience and more importantly we're
not going to lose any money but once we
get to 65 Fletching we can start making
Diamond bolts uh which are actually
pretty profitable okay there we go we're
just about to hit another Fletching
level uh we're going to hit 60 Fletching
just off these mapel long bows and I
think we're going to do them all the way
till uh 65 then we'll switch over to
maybe just doing Diamond bolt tips or
not tips we're going to be actually
combining adment bolts and Diamond bolt
tips into Diamond bolts and uh with this
technique you can actually profit
anywhere from 700k to a mill an hour
that being said there's a buying limit
that restricts it uh of 10K per 4 hours
and you can do about 205k of them an
hour so it's a little bit of an issue
but in short burst uh it can be
profitable and and it won't uh kill your
hands all right there is level 64
Fletching and I thought I had the
perfect amount of logs uh in my bank but
unfortunately I don't think I do I only
have 146 left uh which I'm impressed how
I managed to mess that up so badly
considering I have a calculator in OS bu
that pretty much tells you how many you
need H that's okay okay so we bought all
the maple logs for I think seven GP each
and we're selling the maple long bows
for 92 each uh which means we're going
to profit probably
350k off of these 4,000 logs took about
I don't know 2 hours so it's not great
money but it is still profit which is
nice okay so one thing we're going to be
doing is actually dismantling some
Serpentine visages uh just to had enough
money for this so what you basically do
is you buy uh this Ser Visage and you
hit dismantle and you're going to get
20K Zar scales and sometimes it's
actually worth more to have the scales
instantly uh able to dismantle it so
we're going to sell these for $119 each
2380 is what we're selling it for and we
bought it for 2330 so 50k profit pretty
well instantly uh which I think is
really good and we sold out the make B
long bows already okay we have another
SHP time Visage coming through uh one
thing worth noting is you can actually
do this with all of these zra items
except for the Onyx uh but you can use
this with magic fangs uh serpent time
Helms sometimes uh and as well uh
tanzanite fangs sometimes work um but I
found the serpentin Visage seems to have
the cheapest price and since you get 20K
scales uh no matter what item you uh
break down it's better to just go with
the cheapest one obviously okay guys
there we go we're just about to hit 65
Fletching and that will unlock uh the
ability to create Diamond bolts also
we've been able to make Ruby bolts for a
while now the benefit of the diamond
bolt method is you can get really good
Fletching experience up to like 175k an
hour while getting a really good profit
so I'm excited to give this a try
Okay so we've accumulated about 4 mil in
our inventory that's going to be pretty
well enough to do a full bind limits
worth of the bolts so all we've done is
check the price of the diamond bolts and
just subtracted off the price of the
adment bolts and the diamond bolt tips
and right now we're left with about a I
think was a 20 to 25 GP margin uh per
bolt combination and you can do 10 at a
time so you're getting about 250 GP like
every second uh and really good
Fletching experience so let's see how
much we make off the 9k yeah this
Fletching experience is so good we're up
to 1 90k right now and uh look so you
just make 10 70 experience 70 experience
70 experience is very quick uh it's not
super click intensive but you do have to
pay attention all right so we're just
finishing up the 9k and we got a
Fletching level so from 9k then we got
about 70k fling experience in about 20
minutes uh a little bit more probably
but still extremely good so we're going
to go off and see how much the diamond
bolts are selling for right now and
looks like they're selling for 470 so
we'll sell these off for let's see what
the margin is first actually so 470 -
240 - 190 so we're going to sell them
for 4 mil 221k and if we subtract off
our cost it looks like we're going to be
left with about 350k for 20 minutes work
uh that's about a mill an hour I'd say
uh pretty good all right the diamond
bolts have sold uh didn't take too long
for those and on top of that we've sold
off our super anti- poisons which is
going to bring our cash stack up to
about 4.7 mil uh so we're about halfway
to the 10 mil mark and of course it's
going to start speeding up now okay so
it seems like the margin is still really
good 34 now uh so we're going to go
ahead and buy another I guess we can
afford 10k of these now so we'll buy
another 10K adamant bolts and another
10K Diamond bolt tips and we'll have to
leave this in for a while cuz we did hit
the bind Lim already but it's just a
good daily thing to do so we're going to
get into a habit of doing this um
because we do have the money for it now
and there we go okay we're just
finishing up the other 10K bolts uh we
did hit another Fletching level bringing
us to 60 seven Fletching and as well we
made probably another 300K roughly we'll
have to recheck the margin again cuz
this item does change a lot in price
quite a bit uh so about 460 is what
we're selling it for and let's go
calculate the profit again so we're
selling it for $45.90 taking off 1910 as
well as
2320 it's going to leave us with 360k in
profit uh and another only 20 25 minutes
of work okay so uh one other thing I've
noticed is we can actually upgrade our
combat gear if someone on the last video
suggested I just buy a warrior ring uh
which I thought why not and as well as
we can upgrade our gear to adment still
extremely newbie but look at that we got
the glory we got the Warriors necklace
we got the combat bracelet this is
full-on try hard okay we're taking our
new adamant armor for a spin working out
pretty well so far we're just put to hit
another strength Milestone give to me 35
strength I think our Max hit now is up
to about nine uh which is okay I guess
getting a little sick of these guards
but I mean eventually we'll have access
to something new I guess so I said I
wasn't going to include as much flipping
in this episode uh we're just getting
some really good flips coming in so I
can't not report them this one we got
190k profit on and it was a very quick
flip once again we just combined all the
pages into the page sets through the GE
and sold them uh for 190k profit so
that's pretty good okay so what the plan
is is first we're going to go for uh 40
strength for the higher Max hit as well
as just better experience and then we're
going to go for 40 uh attack so we can
get the Rune simitar also going to
increase our Max that then we're going
to go for 40 uh defense uh and then we
can actually wear some better armor on
top of that we can wear the green dehy
set I do realize we can't actually wear
the body without dragon slayer but
that's not a huge deal cuz we'll hit 50
soon enough and it won't be that big a
deal but anyway there's 40 strength okay
still on the combat grind we're just
about to hit 35 attack I guess we're
getting a little more accurate here uh
but it's not a great place to train that
being said I do see like 10 people
occasionally in a world and I have no
clue why there's a party in the palace
happening but it's not not a great place
uh to party I guess uh but conveniently
enough we're actually going to hit a
farming level on top of that mainly just
doing this for the total level because
the experience- wise uh this is
pointless but we can grow cabbages so
that's okay I guess uh we do have a
bunch of flips coming in uh which I
thought was worth noting Super Attack we
bought for 500k and sold for 625 after
decanting the uh energy potions we got
for 682 and sold for 735 only 60k there
and we have a couple more of the
decanting flips coming in but they're a
little messy just because of the way I
had to sell them uh and we also flipped
a bucket Helm G it took a while but we
made about 150k on that which is
whatever pretty good I guess for the
price now one thing I wanted to do is
actually level up my smithing uh so
we're going to be casting the super heat
item spell uh but we're going to have to
do a couple tests to see what experience
rate is the best because I know it's
kind of expensive okay there's level
five smithing currently getting about 10
an hour and not sure how much this is
costing us yet but I think iron or will
be more cost efficient but yeah this
isn't too bad we can actually spam click
this which is kind of nice there we go
10 smithing relatively quickly still
doing the bronze bars and these 500 will
actually get us to 15 which is nice and
then we can switch over to iron ore uh
but this is really expensive uh although
you could imag also take into account
that we're getting magic experience as
well so we're just about to hit 15
smithing and it's still going relatively
quickly uh we can now start smithing the
iron bars but we are I don't want to go
as far as to say we're hemorrhaging
money but we are definitely losing money
I don't know if my account's at the
point where I want to start investing a
lot of money into the skills I want to
be making money from them okay so we're
on to super heat and iron and we're
actually going to hit a mage Milestone
cu the magic experience is actually
pretty good we're getting about 90k and
our super in Iron ore actually it's
closer to 80 but anyway there is 50
magic we can Now cast fire bolt or fire
Banger or something I don't know uh
something better uh if we actually chose
to use that on the guard I don't know
okay and we're just put it once again
another smithing level we're going to go
for 20 for now uh if we really need to
get the total levels later on it won't
be too long long to actually level at
240 but it's kind of expensive uh so I
don't think we're going to actually
follow through with this right now but
anyway we got 20 easy total levels and
uh kind of figured this out for the
future uh so one goal I wanted to hit by
the end of the episode was 70 Fletching
so we're going to do our best to do that
we just finished 1,000 uh U short bows
combining from the U logs and I do
realize um stringing the bows would
actually be quicker experience and more
money but I just felt like afking and it
was much more afkable to just create the
unstrung bows uh that being said I think
we only lost about 20 or 30k so not too
bad okay so while we're waiting for the
you logs to uh get fletched uh and while
waiting I mean I'm taking a break to do
a flip we bought four of the armadel
pages and we're going to be combining
them for a 100K profit on each uh book
combination uh which is great I mean I
just went to a book fair last weekend so
it kind of gave me the inspiration here
uh 400k off of a 4 mil investment is
really good and uh yeah so we're
actually getting up to about 6 mil I
think by the next episode we should be
able to hit the 10 mil Mark okay uh
Fletching is starting to slow down a
little bit uh but we are actually going
to hit 70 fledging just from Fletching
these you uh long bows now I guess we're
on to and uh sorry I think now we can
fletch to you long bow yeah we're doing
a bunch of you short bows but we're not
going to lose much money and now we're
going to be profiting whether we Fletch
or string them but honestly it's going
to shave three hours off of the entire
process if I just decide to string them
so we probably should just go ahead and
do that okay and we managed to get one
more level for fletchy and there is 71
we can now make dragon Stone tipped
runite Bolt I have no clue if that's
going to be profitable at all I've never
actually tried it but that's enough for
today I don't think I can do any more
Fletching but we did make pretty good
progress okay so I got a good idea for
how I can actually train my agility up
quicker and uh on top of that we also
did get all our offers com through which
is nice but the idea is uh well I was
training with one toy mouse but why not
increase that to five toy mice and that
way I can just release them all in a
confined area and then I'll just Spam
click on all of them and I think it will
be better experience uh doing it the gr
exchange is a dumb idea so we're going
to go over to the verac Palace what am I
doing with my life I'm literally in a
corner picking up toy mice and releasing
them for myself it's kind of depressing
if you think about it too much but um
apparently the limit is five so you
can't put more than five on the gr at
once uh but yeah basically I just
release them all one at a time pick them
all up sometimes it takes forever maybe
I'll actually upgrade to a summer pie
that's kind of funny but anyway once I
get them all into the inventory I just
have to right click or actually sorry
left click to wind them all up and then
right click to release them it's a bit
of a pain but uh it's the only way I can
actually train agility so I guess we're
going to do this maybe till five agility
for now we're going to have to space
this out though okay there we go we
finally got an agility level about to
come in ah this is a little bit
infuriating to catch these mous mice uh
but there is four agility I think uh
we're just going to go for one more for
now and then probably level it up as
needed because we're not actually
unlocking anything with agility it's
just for the total levels pretty well
okay there is five pretty much five
agility I think we're capping at at
about 3K agility experience per hour so
you thought trainy agility was bad
regularly don't even get me started on
this uh I guess you could argue the
agility shortcut at the Grand exchange
is available but it doesn't give
experience and it's kind of cheating so
I'm not going to do that but
unfortunately the only agility shortcut
that would be available is in the uh
sewer system and that is like 50 agility
which is just H it's not going going to
happen there going to be so many agility
levels for that and to round out my
Skilling gains for today because I
cannot suffer any more of those agility
levels uh we're going to level up our
crafting a bit uh we were just at 50
crafting but I think we'll try to get it
to 55 for today again we're just doing
the uh glass blowing which is reasonably
quick and not too expensive it's about
80k an hour uh crafting experience and
only about maybe 75 to 100K in material
cost so was really not that bad uh but
there is 55 craft pretty quick we can
now cut Dragon Stones if we wish all
right guys I think that's we're going to
end today's episode so we're going to
start off by looking at how much money
we're ending the episode with now we
started with about 4 mil from the last
episode and we're ending with about 5.7
uh plus some extra stuff in our
inventory now that's about a 2 mil
profit uh but keep in mind we did spend
some of that money as well on leveling
up a couple various skills uh mainly
smithing and I guess a bit on Fletching
but yeah so that's pretty good for our
money and now let's go have a look at
our skills
okay so having a quick look at our
skills uh we finished the last episode
at about 500 total levels we gained
about 70 or more close to 65 I'd say the
bulk of that coming from Fletching which
we got to 71 uh we got our combat skills
for strength to 40 from 30 our attack to
35 uh we got 20 smithing levels and we
got some crafting levels as well extra
five levels to round that out so I hope
you guys enjoyed the episode thanks
again for sticking around all the way to
episode 6 really excited to continue the
series and uh yeah see you guys in
episode number s
[Music]